[Musik]
die kinder der flüchtlinge sind groß
geworden doch ihre welt ist nicht mehr
jene der eltern
das schafft konflikte über 45.000
tamilen leben in der schweiz sind
weitgehend akzeptiert denn sie gelten
als arbeitsam und ehrgeizig und doch ist
ihre gemeinschaft eine geschlossene
gesellschaft geblieben
auch 30 jahre nach der ankunft der
ersten tamilischen flüchtlinge in der
schweiz für sechs eine schwierige
gratwanderung zwischen den zwängen der
tradition und den freiheiten welche die
schweiz verspricht
[Musik]
schönheiten beim aufgeregten bemühen
sich noch schöner zu machen
die jungen familien dürfen sich einen
sari auswählen gesponsert von diesem
tamilischen modegeschäft in luzern das
traditionelle kleidungsstück das
eigentlich bloß ein kostbares fünf meter
langes tuch ist soll dazu beitragen die
frauen ihren traum näher zu bringen
zur ersten miss temmel switzerland
gewählt zu werden und worauf muss bei
der stoff fall geachtet werden
die vorsicht vor zu viel freizügigkeit
ist angebracht denn das nun auch junge
tamilische frauen in der schweiz sich in
einer misswahl messen wollen
das hat unter traditionellen familien
für großen unmut gesorgt
das ist die schuld daran der erfinder
der ersten tamilischen misswahl in der
schweiz in diesen tagen hatte alle hände
voll zu tun
und dazu gehört auch angriffe von allen
seiten abzuwehren
zuerst verschmierten rechtsextreme seine
website mit hakenkreuzen doch mehr zu
schaffen machen ihm die anonymen online
attacken seiner landsleute
bikini tragen
was wird mit den damen noch passieren
nachgegangen was ist der vorteil für
tamilen überwies tarnen und das sind
einfach so alles an die franken
einzelnen eine arglose angelegenheit
eine solche miss wahl sollte man meinen
doch da ist steht die tragische
familiengeschichte und so ist dieses
harmlose vergnügen mit der politik
kollidiert ein aktueller hungerstreik
tamilischer studenten in indien hat die
schutzhütte an veranlasst die misswahl
um einige wochen zu verschieben
klare zeichen setzen dass mir für
kulturpolitik also vitaminen und mit
geiger tamilen und verkündet dass man
mit gegen tamilen wird seine familie
handel mit einer solidaritäts botschaft
verbreitet über das internet versuche
ins ried aran und die miss kandidatinnen
ihre kritiker zu besänftigen versuchen
so zeigen dass schönheit durchaus mit
tamilischen patriotismus einhergehen
kann
wir unterstützen die tamilen in sri
lanka
das ist hammer kasan aus langenthal sie
soll das mist himmel finale moderieren
[Musik]
und moderieren liegt ihr dieser
extrovertierten jungen frau im blut
gegen 100 konkurrenten und
konkurrentinnen ergatterte die gelernte
bankkauffrau einen moderatoren job beim
jugend tv aus hier ist sie nun beruflich
für gute laune zuständig doch tabake
sein kann auch anders die aggressive
tamilische kritik an der miss tremmel
war hat sie nachdenklich gemacht
es ist nicht nur diese erfahrung mit der
mist himmel war schon in ihrer jugend im
bernischen oberaargau hat sie erkannt
dass sie irgendwie zwischen zwei welten
lebt die ihre tamilischen eltern und
jene ihrer schweizer schulfreundinnen
werden noch die generation fordert um
die generationen nachhaltig ich finde
wir besser und dir vor ich ganz gute
miene zum bösen tier war so nicht
sich zurechtfinden zwischen zwei
kulturen das mussten diese tamilischen
secondo es auch auf dem fußballplatz
schaffen die jungen männer spielen heute
beim fc gladbeck zuvor kickten sie in
einer ausschließlich tamilischen liga
doch so fanden sie dort war der fussball
zu stark mit politik vermischt was
gelegentlich sogar zu
handgreiflichkeiten führen konnte
die familie verwandte immer wieder
schlägereien probleme gehen und dadurch
ein held anfangs klar jungs zum schicken
nachdem ihr card jungs nämlich sehr
junges ist und 60 1 besagt die jungen
sind einfach druck wachse und sie denke
ganz anders mit politik nichts zu hören
wenn junge fußballspieler und doch dort
sport im vordergrund
niemand der hintergrund es ist das erste
weitgehend tamilische team im schweizer
fussball
die nationalmannschaft besteht heute
fast zur hälfte aus secondo deren
wurzeln im balkan oder in der türkei
liegen
doch wo sind die jungen fußball
spielenden tamilen mit seite zeigen
gerade noch kein top tamilischer für
spieler
[Applaus]
das ist wie die tante maria genannt
witschi der stürmer muss gegenwärtig
pausieren
ein kreuzbandriss verursacht in einem
fußballspiel zwingt ihn für einige
monate an den spielfeldrand von wo er
nun seine kommentare abgibt meist in
deutscher sprache
und dann kommt sie doch noch zum einsatz
denn nicht als stürmer so doch als ein
ritter
sie lebt mit seiner familie im zürcher
kreis 5 seit 1999 seit er als
achtjähriger nach der flucht aus der
heimat in der schweiz angekommen ist der
start ins neue leben war verstörend für
das kind vor habe damit im klartext
und dann ist auch klappt das sind ja
glücksspiel im st
und das navi blogs und diese ja hier der
partei übernehmen
in seinen jugendjahren erfuhr wie
drastisch dass er in zwei welten liebt
seine schulkollegen see kontos aus dem
balkan vor allem und einige schweizer
hatten viel mehr freiheiten als er der
junge familie zu hause gab es viel
streit ausschläge meisten vitamine so
und aussprache oder was er sagt das wort
und das ist jetzt was sind die folge sie
wurden zum teil konsequenzen bochum
sowie strafbare schlägt aber dazu hätte
mir schon gedanken wie sowieso eine
klappe wieder wie kollegin monika wie
das passt wie sagt man ihr ticket
schweizerin du hier ich danke schon
einiges märkte ist hart war groß preis
gesellschaft
mir ist 2 walter maß weist frank rost 22
zusammen mit einem jüngeren und einem
älteren bruder lebt wie sie in der
elterlichen wohnung
man hat sich nach den turbulenten
jugendjahren irgendwie zusammen gerauft
und auf engem raum arrangiert
durch das leben der eltern und jenes der
jungen sind zu verschieden
da blieb viel sprachlosigkeit gegenüber
dem vater war ja so aber da kommuniziert
wenn ich habe ich sehe von 18 8 wenig
und wenn ich gesehen dann zeigen
smalltalk und zu weisen jetzt so groß
wie tische unter dem ersten kontakt
sofort nicht besser ist also ich ehrlich
gesagt mehr kontakt mit weiß wenn ich du
willst mich und ja ich wünsche mir
wenn's auch wirtschaftlicher
die schule liegt gleich gegenüber wusste
ja dass dank machbarer ja es war eine
mühevolle schmerzhafte zeit den witschi
hatte in der pubertät große probleme
flug fast von der schule sogar die
staatsanwaltschaft musste sich um ihn
kümmern
aber so ist meister klientel in meinem
leben aber so ein großes verbrechen so
unterstütze ich kapitän der phase
naja dass der täter die hunde stützt den
motoren und da kann man dass es wieder
besser wird hat wenig wenig also
unterstützen ruft merkel ruft mit dem
ist immer schwierig als ich mit vortrag
und aber so unterstütze ein wenig wenn
ich wenig sagen wir wenig
der kreis 5 vor jahren noch ein
drogenmarkt ist mittlerweile ein
gefragtes trend quartier geworden und
wie die schweizer sogar ein wenig
patriot darf man sagen der junge familie
fühlt sich hier jedenfalls zu hause
wohnen wie sie ist und der schiefen bahn
weggekommen
was einigen seiner kollegen von damals
nicht gelang
er ist zufrieden auch mit seinem
traumberuf modeberater auch die eltern
die in diesen fällen nicht auftreten
möchten sind gewiss erleichtert
wenngleich sich der vater statt eines
modeberater lieber einen arzt gewünscht
hätte und das sind große nächst der
pläne
in einigen wochen will wird sie zum
ersten mal zurück reisen nach sri lanka
in seine einstige heimat
ein frühlingstag am bahnhof von biberist
grauer kann die schweiz nicht sein
durch die triste es bewegt sich ein
exotisches klein zum kongresszentrum
[Musik]
das ist la wanja sie natur ein tempel
tänzerin in begleitung von mutter und
schwester seit 15 jahren sie den
hinduistischen tempel tanz geht jede
woche zum training
heute ist das jährliche finale der
besten die tamilischen freundinnen sind
an diesem tag konkurrentinnen
der wettbewerb hat bereits begonnen die
teilnehmerinnen staaten in
unterschiedlichen alters kategorien
[Musik]
das make up ist nicht in erster linie
eine sache der schönheit
es soll vielmehr die mimik beim tanz
unterstützen
jeder strich muss von schwester lucina
präzis gesetzt sein
[Musik]
schavan ja ist angespannt sie ist in den
letzten monaten neben ihrem jus studium
kaum mehr zum tanztraining gekommen
zudem hatte sich für heute eine
schwierige rolle vorgenommen
jene der wunderschönen kraftvollen
bötchen chuck die die gegen das böse
kämpft
dann ist nummer 12 angesagt labbadia sie
natur geboren 1990 im bernischen
niederscherli
[Musik]
die erleichterung ist groß es ist
geschafft wenngleich ist dieses jahr zu
keiner medaille reicht es ist nicht
einfach es sind die vor und nachteile es
braucht für kraft das braucht viel
verstanden ist kompromisse
das machen was man mit der kultur aber
jahren beweist amtlich und besucher
einfach mal gucken jetzt bei staatsnahen
firmen besonders fahrt ins ländliche
niederscherli teil der gemeinde köniz
etwas ausserhalb von bern die sie
naturreis waren hier vor 25 jahren die
ersten familien die integration ging so
gut vonstatten dass man ja erst 19 jahre
alt für die sp sogar ins
gemeindeparlament gewählt wurde
vater lux man an die natur eingelangte
im jahre 1983 mit hilfe eines schleppers
in die schweiz wo er im bahnhof von bern
schutz vor der ungewohnten kälte suchte
in sri lanka waren die spannungen
zwischen den singhalesen und der
tamilischen minderheit in einen offenen
bürgerkrieg eskaliert tausende tamilen
ersuchten damals um asyl in der schweiz
da standen sie nun die fremden
dunkelhäutigen menschen im bahnhof auf
den plätzen der stadt bern und weckten
ängste bei den einheimischen
[Musik]
doch bald verschwanden die tamilen von
der straße
lux man an die natur wurde hilfs pfleger
in einem altersheim
andere fanden eine arbeit in hotelküchen
und reinigungsfirmen arbeiten die von
den schweizern verschmäht wurden und so
verstummte auch allmählich die kritik an
den fremden in sri lanka hatten sich die
sie naturreis wie bei terminen üblich in
einer arrangierten hochzeit vermählt
dabei suchen die eltern für ihre kinder
die partner aus doch nun geht die
familie in der schweiz und die drei
kinder zu welt kann schwebt dem vater
für diese ebenfalls eine arrangierte
hochzeit
ich bin ich habe auch viel konnte anfang
ist aber wirklich wenn meine tochter
wird die freude der einzig wirklich
versuchen bringen will
was kann ich machen
im sommer 2012 reisten sie naturreis zum
ersten mal seit der flucht zurück nach
sri lanka mit gemischten gefühlen
immerhin gab ihnen der schweizer pass
etwas sicherheit durch die ankunft im
heimatdorf war eine große enttäuschung
es war niemand mehr dort den sie kannten
alle waren in den letzten 30 jahren
geflohen primarschule war der
sekundarschule in diesem dorf ich habe
keine mensch keine freunde gesehen
niemand wenn wir hier leben kann als
sicherheit ist wichtig das merke ich und
nicht nur geld und werden hier die hier
die sehr sicher ich sehr wichtig ja bin
ich froh und dankbar hier zum leben in
der welt
alemannia war zum ersten mal in der
heimat ihrer eltern
wie war das für sie christa bietet du
richtig oder der ohnehin sehr spezielle
emotionale plötzlich wird jetzt herr
wanja sie natur arbeitet neben ihrem
studium als übersetzerin in der kanzlei
von anwalt gabriel püntener einem
asylrechts spezialisten beraten wird der
fall eines tamilen der sich seit sechs
jahren in der schweiz um asyl bemüht
der familie der in sri lanka wegen
seiner opposition schon im gefängnis saß
fürchtet um sein leben zurück geschafft
wird
ich sage einfach notiert
das sind alles war anwalt könnten hat
zahlreiche weitere dossiers von tamilen
auf dem tisch in der schweiz sind auch
nach dem ende des bürgerkrieges noch
über 3000 asylgesuche hennig denn das
ende dieses krieges bedeutete leider
nicht frieden und versöhnung noch immer
werden in sri lanka familien
benachteiligt werden oppositionelle
verhaftet und gefoltert
neben ihrer übersetzungsarbeit und dem
studium hilft er bei mir an zwei abenden
in der woche ihre mutter bei
putzarbeiten die familien verbundenheit
ist unter terminen ausgeprägt so ist es
für tochter lavinia keine frage dass sie
im elterlichen reinigungsunternehmen
mithilft zumal die mutter tagsüber noch
einer weiteren arbeit in einem heim
nachgeht
mit viel fleiß haben die sie naturreis
in der schweiz den sozialen aufstieg
geschafft
und die kinder sollen es 1 noch besser
haben die universität von gegenüber
dieser die mutter schon vor jahren als
ziel für ihre tochter es geschafft und 7
die freude der mehr als auch wenn
überall uhr geben so geschickt dass
thommy der schweiz sprach über die
lützow ich das so ja eher die sie dann
sehen die erste generation der
dichtigkeit mir sagt aber so viel
verloren der familie und heimat und so
oder so
die zweite generation wie ein
hoffnungsträger
umso größer ist der druck unser prestige
derartig oder und mich aus was sie
verloren haben wir ja der wunsch
erfüllen
also muss ehrlich sagen piep show und
durchziehe und jan immer so aber
irgendwie dominieren ist irgendwie wie
sie versucht versteht wieso da druck die
ausgestattetes minister landewiese oder
das mehrere mode also mit eigene füße
oder besucht weil sie dachten die und
dankte und ausbau des nicht unter
anderem in berlin stand so labbadia sie
natur ein tempel tänzerin und doch hat
sie auch ihre mühen mit der tamilischen
kultur etwa mit dem kasten wiesen wenn
die zweite generation das noch
weiterführt das ist für mich
inakzeptabel wenn er mit seiner
demokratischen staat mehr weidlich
behandelt werden damit menschen gleich
behandeln
die junge frau ist noch ungebunden doch
ihren partner will sie selber finden
eine arrangierte hochzeit wie in der
tamilischen kultur üblich kommt für sie
jedenfalls nicht infrage
nach dem standard und je nach
integrationsgrad ich sage was tochter
oder sohn der familie
der schweizer familie
und wenn man gemeinsam skinhead dass
männer die verschiedene zelebration
hindu ist die stadt machen
wie tante maria genannt wie der adrette
junge mann aus zürich kreis 5 ist in
colombo sri lanka angekommen es ist
seine erste reise zurück seit er im
alter von acht jahren mit seinen eltern
in die schweiz geflohen war
zeitweise wird auf dieser reise von
seiner mutter begleitet und das ist gut
so denn wickie ist dieses land das einst
seine heimat war völlig fremd geworden
die mutter möchte übrigens möglichst
nicht gefilmt werden
schon nach wenigen schritten ist klar
dass wickie nicht als rückkehrer auf die
insel gereist ist er als staunender
tourist zahlreiche besuche von
verwandten stehen nun auf dem programm
die meisten sind im schmuckgeschäft
tätig auch welches vater führt in zürich
einen schmuckladen schmuckhändler ist
das auch eine kaste der modeberater aus
der schweiz ist nicht mehr für diese
welt gemacht
zu heiß zu laut zu schmutzig sprachen
studiert aber anders verhalten als in
der schweiz
[Applaus]
ende
langweilig wir gehen da lachen
mittagsschlaf eine nacht lang dauert die
busfahrt quer über die insel richtung
vatikan und ohne unterlass kämpfen die
helden vor den bösen passagieren gegen
das böse in batticaloa entschließt sich
wickie für einen drastischen stil
wechseln
ein experiment am eigenen kopf schon
längst habe er den radikalen schnitt
wagen wollen in sri lanka ist nun der
mut dazu greift
[Musik]
budget ist nun schon seit einigen tagen
in sri lanka und gewiss touristisch
bietet das land das eine oder andere
doch heimische gefühle die sich die
mutter bei ihrem sohn wünscht haben sich
bei wickie keine eingestellt
das ist unheimlich schön ist wirklich
fragen
wir haben es wirklich fragt leben hat
das lautsprecher wurde und einfacher da
passen wir mit weniger oder durch damit
sie unsere lang hart trifft wiki watch
on russia kummer als familientherapeut
hatte dieser in seiner zeit in zürich
geholfen aus den turbulenzen der
pubertät herauszukommen rajakumar wald
gegenwärtig in seiner alten heimat und
kann die ablehnende reaktion des jungen
mannes verstehen die reaktion kam vor
zwei jahren in sri lanka schießen vortag
es ist voll leben ist sehr schwierig es
braucht es im ersten kulturschock
zweiten ist erkennt friedlich sieht es
auf der fahrt ins hinterland von partie
calor dabei sind hier noch vor wenigen
jahren familien aus politischen gründen
entführt gefoltert ermordet worden
[Applaus]
sie stammt aus einer hinduistischen
familie doch den tempel besucht er eher
in touristischer manier
welche bedeutung hat für ihn die
religion immer ländlicher wird die
umgebung wie sie ist auf der reise zum
haus seiner kindheit dass er als großes
gebäude in erinnerung hat
wolfgang
verschossen
jetzt will
um sich zu schützen
[Musik]
da mache ich mit großen coup von britta
wirtz
[Musik]
leute aus der ganzen umgebung kommen den
jungen mann zu bestaunen der ein wenig
aussieht wie sie und doch aus einer
anderen welt stand hier war der vater
lehrer hat sich für die unabhängigkeit
der familien eingesetzt und musste
fliehen doch so genau weiß es wird sie
auch nicht und fast will erscheinen als
ob er es auch nicht wissen möchte dass
er mit diesen kriegsgeschichten mit
diesen erinnerungen nichts mehr zu tun
haben wir das ist grob er an kasami
genannt q der sich zum pflegefachmann
ausbilden lässt
er arbeitet für eine private luzerner
spitex organisation
es ist sonntagabend und sein letzter
einsatz an diesem tag führt ihn zu
dieser gehbehinderten klientin bei
seinen regelmäßigen besuchen hilft er
ihr das leben und essen mühen zu
bewältigen
es sind intime momente und oft sind es
familien die diese arbeit leisten
denn bei schweizern ist nicht sehr
beliebt arbeitsschluss für den
22-jährigen pur
er muss heute noch nach und nach weiter
fahren wo er wohnt kuru kam vor zehn
jahren als flüchtling in die schweiz
es war das ende einer traumatischen
reise um die halbe welt ein bild seines
vaters das einzige das es gibt großvater
wurde in sri lanka im bürgerkrieg
getötet 1991 was kurz bevor der sohn zur
welt kam
in kilinochchi worum mit seiner mutter
und der schwester lebte tobten die
kämpfe unvermindert weiter
und im jahre 2001 beschloss die mutter
nicht auch noch ihren einzigen sohn
verlieren zu wollen
sie schickte das neunjährige kind allein
mit einem schlepper auf die flucht auf
einem kleinen fischerboot über das meer
nach indien sie aber nicht mehr so ein
tuch gegeben weil das hat ziemlich kalt
auf dem meer und zum umwickeln und es
ist immer wieder wasser im boot
hineinschaut gekommen und muss immer
wieder genau genau schaufeln und das hat
wellen gehören melden gehabt und und das
war für mich das schlimmste konnte ein
schwimmen konnte nicht
nach einer dreijährigen irrfahrt durch
zahlreiche länder brachte ein schlepper
coro zu asyl empfangsstation im
schweizerischen kreuzlingen
es war im februar 2004 der bub war nun
zwölf jahre alt und allein
kuru kam zu einer tamilischen
pflegefamilie in zug
bilder aus einem film den er damals mit
freunden drehte im frühling 2009 ging
der bürgerkrieg in sri lanka seinem
blutigen ende entgegen cousins
nächtelang vor dem bildschirm
ich habe immer die nachrichten gefolgt
und gelesen und da sind die mengen menge
von menschen gesorgt
diesen tag oder alleine im letzten zwei
monaten sind mehrere tausend tamilen ums
leben gekommen
und unter diesen gejagten glaubte kourou
seine mutter und die schwester zu sehen
auf der flucht vor den bomben der
regierungstruppen kourou brach zusammen
es bringt nichts wenn ich da das sind
die schule zu gehen leben oder das ist
alles vorbei so habe ich das wirklich
eine bernard für mich und ja
ein halbes jahr später erfuhr kourou
dass mutter und schwester überlebt haben
in einem umerziehungslager der regierung
ein goldener spätsommertag
es ist der tag auf den kourou seit
vielen jahren gewartet hat seit 14
jahren
am flughafen wartet schon chorus
verlobte nieroba niro genannt auch hans
peter roth ist da seien sogar
rechtsbeistand crew nennt den götti
diesen väterlichen freund der ihn durch
die elternlose jugend begleitet hat
nur noch wenige minuten können es sein
bis die mutter kommt doch diese minuten
dauern eine ewigkeit
fast als letzte der passagiere erscheint
eine schüchterne schmächtige frau am
ankunft portal
o
tja ist ein glücklicher tag gewartet
die mutter ist da in einigen tagen kann
die hochzeit stattfinden
an einem septembertag vermählen sich
chor und niveau auf dem standesamt von
uznach boni rom mit ihren eltern lebt
und wo auch das junge paar seinen
wohnsitz haben wird die standesbeamtin
bemüht sich redlich den summen breche
rischen tamilischen namen gerecht zu
werden ist es auch ihr wohl schon freie
wille mit der korrupten die egal zu
gehen
durch die bereits artige zustimmung
erkläre ich die ehe ausgeschlossen
anschließend findet in einem
evangelischen gemeindezentrum das fest
für familie und freunde statt
[Musik]
auch hans peter roth ist gekommen er
erinnert sich an kourou an einen buben
der bach und neugierig war denen ich und
ich hatte damit wurden und sie nicht das
größte geheimnis herz berührt und nico
haben sich in der gemeinsamen ausbildung
zur pflegefachfrau gelernt die junge
frau wurde ihm der ohne mutter und vater
aufwuchs der heftig ins taumeln geraten
war
zur wichtigen stütze und niehues eltern
diesen der tochter die wahl eine
arrangierte hochzeit war nicht gefordert
dankbar ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine einfamilienhaussiedlung am dorf
handvoll uznach im haus der braut eltern
wohnt nun für einige wochen auch
großmutter die in der schweiz ihren
verlorenen sohn wiedergefunden hat ich
war das damals für dich hast du mich auf
die flucht geschickt hast das hat mich
sehr traurig gemacht ich wollte dich
nicht weggeben und das wiedersehen am
flughafen
ich war sehr glücklich sehr glücklich
denn ich konnte zuvor nicht mehr daran
glauben die ich je wieder zu sehen
ich war einfach sehr glücklich
havanna sie natural studiert
rechtswissenschaften an der universität
bern internationale
entwicklungszusammenarbeit dies könnte
für sie eine künftige betätigung sein
schavan ja hat es geschafft und sie hat
es auch ein wenig für ihre eltern
geschafft dies unterscheidet sie wohl
von ihren schweizer freundinnen die eine
solche verpflichtung weniger spüren und
beim kaffeetrinken im schweizer
freundeskreis wird dir wieder klar dass
sie zwischen zwei welten pendelt dass
die diskussionen hier anders verlaufen
als bei ihren tamilischen freundinnen
[Applaus]
ihr täglicher weg führt sie durch den
berner bahnhof es ist dieser ort wo ihr
vater vor 30 jahren schutz vor der
ungewohnten kälte suchte wo das leben
der familie sie natura in der schweiz
ihren anfang nahm
heute ist der tag an dem die erste miss
travel switzerland gewählt werden soll
veranstalter t shirts rita ran macht
sich für einen langen tag bereit die
elterliche wohnung im obwaldner rischen
sachseln ist voll mit bekannten die als
helfer für den abend eingespannt sind
die letzten tage waren für den jungen
mann ein einziger nervenkrieg die
anonymen gegner im internet gaben keine
ruhe und deckten ihn mit bösen
verleumdungen vor der staat den
angestellten der konzertveranstalter
ohne den kulturen unter sich denn mit
der frauen-wm es schafft wird mache im
bereich vor der prostitution und t
shirts vita an der eigentlich bloß mit
etwas geschäft sind einen unterhaltungs
event anbieten wollte ist mitten in
einen heftigen kultur kampf geraten
im saal des hotels national in bern
laufen die vorbereitungen für den abend
auf hochtouren
moderatorin tamara kasan muss als seelen
coach die kandidatinnen beruhigen
340 junger tamilen hatten sich für diese
wahl angemeldet nach einem
internet-voting sind neun geblieben die
nun auf den sieg heute abend hoffen
das missfiel halle hat bereits zwei
stunden verspätung
und noch immer sind viele stühle leer
als der event endlich doch noch beginnt
verdeckt die dunkelheit im saal gnädig
das nur wenige hundert leute zur ersten
wahl gekommen sind
es sind vor allem verwandte und freunde
der kandidatinnen
[Musik]
und es zeigt sich dass die ganze
vorsorgliche aufregung um zu viel nackte
haut und zu wenig tamilische kultur
unberechtigt war dieser jungen familien
geben an diesem abend nicht mehr preis
als traditionelle tempel tänzerinnen
doch diese erkenntnis nützt
veranstalters reed aran nicht mehr viel
die erste miss teen wahl ist für ihn zur
kostspieligen enttäuschung geworden
wenigstens darf wie schnee kilometer
sein lachen
die jury wählt die kv lehrtochter aus
ostermundigen zur schönsten doch selbst
deren würdigung will nicht ganz gelingen
noch während der verkündigung verlassen
die zuschauer den saal wohl auch etwas
genervt von der stundenlangen verspätung
einige tage später hat er an die
rechnung gemacht ein paar tausend
franken hat in die schönheitskonkurrenz
gekostet und besonders verstörend
hasserfüllt der blogeinträge attackieren
nun auch die siegerin vision der sekunde
aus bern wird vorgehalten sie spreche
kein tadelloses tamilisch weshalb sie
sich keinesfalls mit termin nennen dürfe
bloß eine harmlose miss wahl war geplant
die unerbittlichkeit einiger landsleute
hat tritt er an jedoch zwischen hammer
und amboss geführt
alle jahre im november feiern die
tamilen in der schweiz ihre helden die
im kampf um die unabhängigkeit getötet
worden sind
mit großer ergriffenheit beschwören sie
dabei die tamilische einheit auch kurve
und miro sind in die forums halle von
freiburg gekommen
an einer endlos scheinenden wand sind
1500 bilder aufgereiht väter söhne
schwestern brüder im krieg getöteten
termin tigers märtyrer des tamilischen
kampfes gurus eigene grausame biografie
hat sein bewusstsein geschärft für die
sache der tamilen
[Musik]
tausende kommen jeweils hierher und ihre
gesichter erzählen traurige geschichten
doch andere bleiben zuhause junge
secondo es etwa sie möchten den
kriegserinnerungen ihrer eltern
entrinnen möchten zb einfach fußball
spielen ohne in einen politischen streit
verwickelt zu werden und so stellt sich
die frage aller immigranten wieviel alte
heimat soll man mitnehmen wenn man dabei
ist in einer neuen anzukommen
[Musik]